I probably Matt,
Matt massacre that name says who has a
higher Iq.
I really gifted mathematician or a
really gifted painter,
very difficult to say.
Um,
but I would say that gifted math,
because if they're both gifted,
they both have high Iq,
so you can be certain of that.
It's very difficult to do anything
that's truly gifted,
say above the average,
above the norm without being,
without having a very high Iq and in a
creative realm.
I mean you hear about these idiot savant
who have like one area of extreme
expertise,
but generally in those cases it's not so
much that they have one area of extreme
expertise,
it's that they have one area of above
average expertise that really contrast
with the rest of their impairments,
but they rarely if ever,
make it into the,
you know,
the very short list of true geniuses.
Mathematicians are kind of an odd bunch
though because you,
they peek really,
really early.
Like if you're going to be a
mathematician and truly gifted,
then you're going to show signs of that
when you're like 17 to 20 something like
that.
Whereas painters can,
can be creative through their entire
lifespan.
Um,
I would say probably on average,
I would guess this is a guest that if
you took a hundred really gifted
mathematicians and a hundred really
gifted painters,
that the mathematicians would have far
higher nonverbal Iq,
but the painters might have higher
verbal Iq was.
So that also complicates things seat
with Iq.
Also,
you know,
there's,
there's this factor called the g factor,
which is the central element of
intelligence.
And it seems to be associated with such
things as head size and brain size
relative to body and neural conduction
speed and simple reaction time,
like really basic physiological markers.
Um,
and it's a pretty tight single factors
say as opposed to the personality
dimension domain where there's five
quite clear factors.
But I think it was Earl hunt research
indicated that as people get smarter and
smarter,
the variability between the subsets of
their intelligence starts to increase.
So it's sort of like,
there's a lot of ways to be really
smart,
but there's only one way to be not very
smart.
So,
um,
that's another little tidbit of
information with regards to Iq.